in a small room in an empty football
stadium for conservative candidates and
the Prime Minister her first and only
campaign stop ahead of next week's
European elections if you want a party
that works in the national interest vote
conservative this Bristol event was a
carefully choreographed affair just five
members of the media let in outside most
journalists kept away eager to ask about
what had taken place minutes before the
Labour leader calling an end to cross
party brexit talks saying no compromise
deal was possible the government is not
fundamentally shifted its field and a
division of the Conservative Party in
minutes of government is negotiating
with no authority and no ability that I
can see to actually deliver anything
answering the one question journalists
were allowed to ask her today Theresa
May said it was labour who were to blame
we haven't been able to overcome the
fact that there isn't a common position
in labour about whether they want to
deliver brexit or hold a second
referendum which could reverse it
when MPs come to vote on the bill they
will be faced with a stark choice that
is to vote to deliver on the referendum
to vote to deliver brexit or to shy away
again but was the writing always on the
wall for these talks
Bristol voted 62% to remain and has four
Labour MPs many here want the party to
be opposing brexit not letting it happen
we tried asking for a general election
we couldn't get that through we've tried
compromising and negotiating with her it
didn't get anywhere as far as I'm
concerned labour party policy on this is
clear we have to go back to the people
this is likely to be one of the last
appearances to resume makes campaigning
as captain of her team maneuvering is
already well underway to replace her in
number 10 and it's that uncertainty that
concerns labour not knowing if a future
Prime Minister would honor the promises
made by this one brexit certainly isn't
child's play the numbers in Parliament
will be the same for the next prime
minister tough challenges will persist
for those who've already said they'll
run maybe stand out to give you a run at
the lead and those who are staying loyal
for now for conservative brexit ears a
more fundamental shift is needed and
perhaps a move towards leaving without a
deal what would command a majority in
parliament is the which oral agreement
without the Northern Ireland backstop
and that that is the way forward and
whether it is this current prime
minister or whether it is her successor
that's got to be taken seriously Theresa
May says she'll now look at putting
various brexit options to MPs and
letting them decide the way forward in a
series of votes but with both main
parties paralyzed by division there's
still no clear route through or end in
sight Rob Powell Sky News in Bristol